[Musique]
nous sommes à l'école hôtelière de
lanaudière est ici on n'a pas à cuisiner
locales et légumes y sont ils sont déjà
dans ses amis en brunoise où je pense
que lanaudière on l'interrogé formidable
palette des autres régions au québec on
a la chance d'avoir un peu de tout je
voulais savoir une opinion avant de vous
dire ce que j'en pense vraiment de le
faire dans un commerce c'est bien mais
de le faire dans l'enseignement c'est
parce qu'on veut faire des petits ce
soir ça a aidé les autres étudiants
cuisine pour les clients du restaurant
de l'école avec plusieurs produits de la
région
chacune mais boucher je voulais intégrer
un des produits régionaux qu'on a les
premiers mois je fais des 1 pén hadas
aux bisons de la terre des bisons à
rawdon j'utilise des boutons de
marguerite dans mon tartare de tomate
qui mène de l'abbaye devant notre dame
j'utilise duboc et ses fromages d'ici je
fais ta g une tunisie puis j'utilise ce
fromage le à l'intérieur je mettrai plus
de fromage et s'avance la fleur de sel
fumé sur toi ça il va gratuit en
décembre mais il a commencé à intégrer
le concept de rapprochement des
producteurs dans le restaurant où ils
travaillent déjà
on a un producteur qui vient nous voir
dans son camion avec des produits
revient derrière on les sent les gouttes
on on les choisit nous même si ça peut
vous être plus frais que ça c'est du
producteur au restaurant ya pas une
serre entre les deux c'est de la terre à
l'assiette
je trouve ça beau jeu
parce que c'était de l'ortie si
l'apprentissage se fait à l'école il se
fait aussi sur le terrain les deux mains
dans la terre même avec la pluie et le
froid des comportements c'est ce
colloque pour la même raison que les
autres dans deux semaines ça va être
clean laquelle on découvre et on cueille
tout ce que la forêt offre comme
produits comestibles et ses amis je vous
présente enfin pour pour qu'on va
trouver à l'état naturel en forêt payer
pour par le toqué on visite aussi
directement les producteurs comme la
courgerie de sainte-elisabeth à quelques
kilomètres de l'école voilà le principal
avantage c'est que tu vu grandir ton
produits frais pour le processus je les
vois plainte et je vais voir avancer je
peux aller voir mes coaches que les
choisir quand tu achètes par exemple une
courge
aux grandes surfaces ou peu importe je
sais pas quand est-ce qu'elle est écrite
c'est mon pote d'où est-ce qu'elle
vienne est à la limite c'est toujours
meilleur une fois que ces puits le bêta
carotène vaut davantage ressortir c'est
tellement bons qu'ils aient fait qu'ils
montent et exploiteurs dans une course
mais que cette fois on peut discuter
avec le producteur qui sont vraiment
rentables
parfois c'est le producteur local qui
vient directement approvisionnés l'école
c'est le cas de pierre luc forget de
cochon cent façons ça se fait waouh
c'est parfait je vais fermer terrine
avec ce puissant mais c'est au
restaurant ce soir donc il ya aucun
problème
parfait cool merci bonne journée l'ol
est tout intégré ce concept de
rapprochement c'est bon pour juste pour
la santé pour juste pour l'économie
locale c'est bon aussi pour l'empreinte
écologique c'est bon pour plein de
raisons semblent c'est déjà tous je vous
présente les comme estime conjuguer
ensemble nous avons ici les pensées
c'est vraiment très bon au printemps de
la chance de vivre dans un pays où il ya
quatre saisons quatre fois plus de
possibilité d'aller chercher chaque
saison sa petite saveur changer sa carte
change son menu y aller avec la création
tout le temps
[Musique]
cuisiner avec les produits de la région
ne comporte pas que des avantages
qu'on se le cachera pas ça coûte un peu
plus cher quelqu'un qui produit 1
hectares de pommes de terre exemple bah
c'est sûr qu'il aura pas le même
rendement que quelqu'un qui fait 40
hectares de pommes de drame donc sa
patate va forcément être plus cher
[Musique]
médium saignant ouais on lève la ficelle
suite police et les soins dentaires
quand jour là mais ton producteur est
appelé à juger plus de rutabaga effet tu
t'adaptes la plupart du temps les
avantages d'être proche des producteurs
c'est qu'ils vont trouver une
alternative
j'ai plus de doute à bagua mais est ce
que tu veux voir mon nouvel arrivage
quand j'étais vraiment découvert une
passion à creuser le sol à oui mais je
suis excusé
je me lavais chaque matin en me disant
que je prends la chose qui me fait le
plus plaisir
[Musique]